all right guys bang-bang we have the
absolute pleasure hopefully of being
blessed by miss Pauline Amer Nova my
fiance the founder of the profile and a
bunch of other amazing cool things
thanks for doing this thank you for
having me
can't believe I'm doing this but here I
am she's been a static that she now has
the chance to come on here answer some
questions I'm going to interview her and
then she is likely to bust my balls and
give me a hard time so let's get started
you're not from the United States did
you just figure that out
tell us your story so I was born in
Bulgaria and my dad won a green card
actually my mom won a green card my dad
filed in 1999 so we moved to the United
States when I was 8 or 9 years old
where's Bulgaria a lot of people don't
know where that is
it's right above it borders Greece and
Turkey and Romania okay let's talk about
the citizenship application process I
know the story obviously of how your dad
won it and I'll just summarize it with
he basically looked around the room and
said who's every single person I could
file for citizenship to win this green
card cuts the lottery and kind of the
more shots on goal you get the higher
your chances your mom won it but then
there's a whole process that goes into
it maybe we talked a little bit about
just like how that actually works yeah
it's super interesting because I think
this visa is not the common ones that
people come on it's technically
considered the diversity lottery visa
program I can't remember which President
started it but essentially they started
it in hopes of attracting people from
different countries and having them
immigrate in a legal way but the reason
it's a lottery and not you know a
merit-based is the
a lot of these countries there's a ton
of corruption so even if you are like
okay let's have you take a test and then
you can come a lot of times it's like
the corrupt politicians kids who are
gonna take the test because you know
it'll it just doesn't work this latter
is awesome cuz like anybody can apply
and if you get it you still have to
prove a lot of stuff you have to have
graduated from high school they look at
they do a background check I think you
have had to work for several years all
that stuff that they look for and then
it takes the whole process takes about a
year you go to the u.s. embassy
you have to interview with them and then
they ask you questions like you know
what are you gonna do there do you have
family that you can stay with so that
you can prove you're not going to come
to the US and be homeless and you know
could those people greet you at the
airport provide a place to live and help
you find a job so yeah my family didn't
know anybody in the United States but I
think my grandfather amused some people
who were here and happy to to greet us
got it and so it's obviously a really
complex and hard process to navigate but
once you get to the United States you're
eight nine years old like what is that
like eyes barely speak English let alone
having come here and didn't speak
English like how do you navigate that
yeah it's definitely your time mainly
because I got pulled out of second
grader Bulgaria and I came to Atlanta
and did not speak any English but you're
a kid so I so we moved here in April so
I spent the summer kind of like watching
TV and trying to understand English who
before school and I started school in
August but for some unknown reason they
put me in fourth grade here and I the
the biggest I didn't speak any English
but the biggest advantage I had was that
in Bulgaria and second grade we were
solving for x in math and I was terrible
in math
there but here people thought I was a
genius so like I walk into fourth grade
and they're like okay guys like we're
gonna solve 4+7 I was like oh my god
this is a dream so I was you know
amazing at math really struggled with
English and reading but I was in that
yes so well class the English is a
second language
ESL I don't know mine had an O OSL yes
Oh L I don't know so then my teacher
there Miss Anne Jackson I will never
forget her she kind of saw potential in
me she saw you know secure yes I liked
books but I couldn't really understand
them so she would start with like the
baby books like the really small basic
books
make me go home with them and then tell
me like go home use the dictionary and
translate the words until you understand
so that's what I did and then like the
level of book escalated from there and I
loved it all right so you're doing that
and that's kind of like the academic
side what what was like the social side
I feel like most kids have like either
really good experiences really bad
experiences and you get all the clicks
everything in like high school and all
that what's that like coming from
another country I mean so yeah like in
high school you get the cliques but
elementary school like kids are brutal
they do not care because they have no
social filter they don't think like oh I
might hurt their feelings yeah I was a
savage you know III have a feeling we
wouldn't have been friends but so of
course like and I totally get it now but
like moving from a different country in
fourth grade of course you're like the
weird kid that's gonna get picked on
that doesn't speak English like it's
just terrible and so I didn't really
have many friends there was a girl in my
class was also from Bulgaria so I had
her but you guys speak Bulgarian yes and
actually got in trouble in Spanish class
for speaking Bulgarian and not English
and not Spanish so that's a lot of
languages going on
all right so you do all of this at what
point do you realize that you want to go
to the University of Georgia and
eventually become a journalist yeah so
it's really funny when I was little my
family was like religious about watching
the news and I was really chatty as you
can imagine still are and so they they
were always like oh my god like please
stop talking so I can watch the news and
I hated the news I like I knew when that
thing came on I couldn't speak so it was
just like a horrible time for me but
then I went to high school and that was
pretty shy like I didn't I didn't like
talking to new people or strangers for
no reason like there was I was like why
would I ever do that like I have my
friends I don't need to embarrass myself
and talk to other people so I was pretty
shy and then one of my friends joined
the school newspaper and I was like oh
cool like that's an elective that's not
you know PE or like music so I joined it
too and I really liked writing like I've
always liked writing um I didn't like
talking to people
but the newspaper actually gave me an
excuse in a weird way to talk to
strangers because I was I had a job to
do so he kind of it was really
interesting like I got to talk to all
sorts of people and like interview the
principal you know how big of a deal
that isn't I was not trying to talk to
the other they wanted to talk to me but
I you know so yes it was I had the best
time so I loved writing articles I liked
to interviewing people I liked writing
and from there I just went like all in
to the journals on path and it's I don't
know if like I was actually in the
science program in high school because I
was a nerd both my parents were a
chemical engineer so I was like I love
chemistry but then I found that I
actually liked writing those 15-page lab
reports much more than doing the
experiment and I still remember like my
friends would be like oh holy nose in
our group like she'll blow up the whole
thing so I just wrote the lab
so you mentioned that you didn't take
the electives like PE and that type of
stuff
were you athletic um I was athletic HS
alright we'll come back to this story
well depends on who you're asking
yeah sure we'll come back to this part
of the story alright so you decide that
hey I really like journalism you go to
the University of Georgia what was that
like it was great I really didn't want
to go there cuz I just thought it would
be high school over again seeing people
saying whatever but when there's 35,000
people on campus you find that there's
new groups and people
uga had one of the best journalism
programs in the country so you have to
apply to get in I got in I also worked
at the school newspaper and started
working there as a freshman and worked
my way up to editor-in-chief when I was
a senior for those of us that don't
understand the newspaper editor and
she's like the boss it's like the boss
they have an office oh really
yeah that's not popular today in offices
but I get we're remoting now it's
quarantine time you just you zoom it's
perfect look at our office now
alright so speaking of the school
newspaper you made national headlines in
college for basically being a gangster
and leaving a walkout tell us about this
I know all the secret so I get asked all
the questions yeah and it's so funny
that it was like cuz you know me like
I'm not very rebellious or looking for
trouble but basically what happened was
the student newspaper is independent and
has a board of directors so it's in no
way affiliated with the school or
anything like that we have our own
advertising rubs we have people
advertise that's how it makes money so
at the time this is 2012 I had you were
still in school in 2012 I was a senior
gee oh yeah cuz you're like a child go
ahead so fall of 2012 on like a senior
I'm ready to go I finally like
editor-in-chief like my dream
all my life and suddenly this rogue
board member from the Board of Directors
comes into the newsroom and says you
know what or losing a ton of money you
guys don't know what you're doing we're
just gonna basically take away student
independence and have a professional run
this and that's it and I was just like
yeah that's not gonna happen because you
the student newspaper has been
independent since I think the 70s and
for a very very long time what does that
mean independent like it's not reliant
on its its own business it's not reliant
on the university for okay so it and and
students have always had the final say
so no matter what like the reason it was
school to be editor of the school paper
is because if somebody made a mistake
you're responsible for it like I would
be on the phone all the time with people
who are upset about something in an
article and would have to defend why we
did it or whatever and then maybe have a
serious conversation with the reporter
afterwards but you were kind of the face
of this institution by the way I'm
laughing because you think that's cool
and that sounds like a nightmare to me
that yeah yeah I got you I can see why
it would be cool to somebody who likes
that it was an amazing and then suddenly
like I'm in the situation where I have
to make an ethical decision of what do I
do like do I keep the do I stay editor
and let this happen or do I not so
basically I called a staff meeting I
told my staff like hey I'm just gonna
step down as editor-in-chief because of
this this and this is like the second
week of school because I just can't be
respondus happens and I just will not
allow somebody to take the editorial and
dependence away from the students so I
said I'm stepping down and it was like
in a movie like you know when if it was
so cool because these were my friends
and because we
work together for 4 years everybody was
like well I'm gonna leave too and I'm
gonna leave too so it was just like
everybody walked out got in our cars and
left and went into this like superhot
apartment it was mid August no a/c and
we just sat there like were we gonna do
now and we definitely didn't think it
would be a big story but that's right
when Twitter was kind of starting to be
big and it went viral on Twitter first
and it got picked up picked up picked up
and then over the course of that day
plus the next day it was in CNN USA
Today like all the major news
publications
long story short there was a lot of
support for the students there were also
of course the people who are like you
spoiled brats like every time you don't
like what's going on in a job can just
like get up and leave which I agree with
but I hope that if I'm ever in a
situation and there's an ethical dilemma
I will always do what's right and that's
what I felt like we did so then yeah so
long story short we met with the board
of directors the students talked to them
and we came to a resolution and the
paper is still independent today all
right good job so how do you get from
Georgia to Fortune magazine where he
worked for 5 years yeah
so I graduated in 2013 no full-time
offers I was freelancing for CNN and USA
Today during the day so I would work at
CNN from 7 a.m. to 4 p.m. drive home and
then from 6 to 11 work at USA Today
remotely I did that for about a year
saved a lot of money and really just
wanted to get to New York I didn't know
how I didn't know what I'd be doing but
I just wanted to get here why why yeah
like why did you want to come to New
York cuz I there's a lot of people who
think that's crazy yeah yeah but to me
it's like I felt like you know weird way
like Atlanta was like too small for what
I wanted to do at least I thought at 21
years old I was like New York is where
media is and like dreams are so that was
where pomp is - you know I
so yes I did
I interviewed a ridiculous number of
places including a newsletter start up
that where I didn't get the job because
they said I didn't have enough
experience with newsletters which is
really funny and now but then I got a
job at Ozzy which is was a media startup
it still is and I moved to New York in
2014
I spent six months at the start-up and
then got a job as the social media
editor at Fortune magazine all right I'm
gonna give you a bunch of [ __ ] this is
not one of the things I'm gonna give you
[ __ ] about you went from the social
media editor at Fortune magazine to
writing term sheet which is probably the
most popular why they read thing in tech
finance business private equity kind of
but those guys are weird
what like how does that happen how do
you do that in a span of three or four
years yeah so like I wrote recently when
I started at fortuned
I didn't know what a term sheet was I
was subscribed to term sheet the
newsletter but I didn't understand a
single word I had no idea what venture
capital was or why people were giving
these startups money most venture
capitalists don't know either
go ahead I didn't know anything but I
thought it was like interesting and I
thought it was something I should learn
about so my goal was by the end of the
year I kept reading it every day and by
the end of the year my goal is to
understand like 10% of what was said in
it after a while you started like
understanding like oh it's like Facebook
bought this little startup and like why
and that's interesting
but I genuinely had no idea what were
some of the weirdest things that you
remember reading that you didn't
understand like I know one time he told
me dry powder yeah the hell is dry
powder yeah right I'm spend money
there's a lot of people who wish they
had try why wouldn't you just say I'm
spent money that's not deployed or well
it's cuz you got to sound cool dry
all right so yeah so anyway so I do that
and then we start a new section called a
fortunate venture which is focused on
small businesses first-time
entrepreneurs kind of learning about the
business side of things if you want to
start a business I did that for about a
year and then and then Dan Primack had
left a fortune to go he had just left
fortune to go do pro rata
Axios and term she was being authored by
Aaron Griffith so I started helping
Aaron compile the term of the deal
section which wasn't that hard right
like it's pretty formulaic you see a
press release of this company bought
this company and you put it in like
don't tell people the secret everyone
thinks it's really hard yeah
it takes a look takes a lot of time
alright so at what point do you go from
doing the deals to actually writing term
sheet so then Aaron leads and there was
a question who the hell is gonna write
Trump sheet and I definitely was not on
my radar I never thought I'd do that
thing that I never previously understood
so in my head I was like absolutely not
I could never do this and then when they
asked me if I wanted to do it I was like
yes absolutely how scared were you
I mean you were here you know how scared
I was how scared I know I've never seen
you so scared for anything in your life
and I was like all you have to do is
write like you were doing this your
whole life yeah it's like in this is the
thing about writing something you're not
confident writing is like I over-prepare
when I'm insecure about something I like
make sure I research it over research
and over prepare interview talk to a
bunch of people so I would literally in
the those first few days I would wake up
at 4:30 a.m. then yell at him because I
was like what the hell they don't read
about today I suck this is horrible what
am i doing and then we would have like
the whole I calm down like it's gonna be
okay and then therapists right here
and then I would like once I call myself
I would start calling people and trying
to figure out you know what was going on
in the news and what I wanted to add to
it alright so while all this is going on
we'll come back to term sheet in a
second
you met the love of your life me tell
this story I got a lot I got a lot of
stories to tell but good you tell
whatever you want to tell I won't
embarrass you okay because he has some
fake news with this story so this is why
I want to tell it first so okay so this
is 2016 I'm just living my life being a
great reporter and I'm just talking on
the internet that's a okay we're having
a very good discussion about
interrupting and mansplaining in this
household so it looks good okay so so
2016 I'm living my life and I used to
have this Facebook show that I did for a
fortune called founder Friday and I
would interview a founder every Friday
on Facebook live so then I would share
the videos on my Facebook page I guess
and people that we know would share them
on there so there was a mutual friend
was on it who shared it and the people
that he knows had liked against the
video so it was at the time right when
Facebook came out with that love feature
like that heart feature so I was like
thumbs up thumbs down laughing face so I
was like who the hell is loving this
video like that is so weird
one of them was my stepmom and the
second person was therapist our friend
right here this guy so I click on his
thing and it's like a very nice picture
of you and your mom like why was it I
was in a tuxedo actually in the photos
my cousin got married in California so
he paid me a lot of money to show up and
wear the tux with go ahead so lovely
great I move on with my if this is this
is like September
and then a few months later I write an
article about like the startup and AI
and all this stuff another friend of
mine how am I supposed to do good and I
what I do is if you guys don't know this
trick it's a great trick if you're a
reporter or if you just want to look at
who shared a link that you like or
whatever you take the link and you put
it in the search bar and it shows you
every person that's ever shared it and
maybe not tagged you so I do that for
all my articles just to see like who's
sharing it who's whatever and who shared
it me so I was like oh my god that's
literally the same guy so then I see in
his Twitter bio that says something
something like venture investor but at
the same time he only has like 500
followers bio never said that but go
ahead something like you you have like
700 followers
meanwhile I had thousands and thousands
so I was like hmm
I mean what's another follow friends so
I just gave me a pity follow and I liked
my article and i retweeted my article so
just so we're clear
just so we're clear I'm taking over now
if you're sitting there and all of a
sudden in your notification you only
have 700 followers you get like no
notifications and then all of a sudden
you're like oh my god this girl liked
retweeted and followed me her she she's
harassing me on the internet she's
stalking and therefore I messaged you
and I said we would translate he slid
into my Twitter diems and what did I say
hey no that is not true that is not true
I said hey I saw your article it was
good I have a whole bunch of companies
we've invested in a particular we have a
whole bunch of companies that we
invested in you should write about some
of those as well or something to that
tell me you said I'm an early stage
investor like maybe we should meet for
coffee I invest in many early-stage
startups I was like yeah sure and I sent
you a list of the companies yes before
we searched every single
and you still have my notes from them
and the ones that have that I said would
implode have imploded yeah the the ones
that if I had just listened to her
advice we probably could have saved a
lot of money but I made more money
actually and so when we met for coffee
you have to tell the story I'll let you
tell the story okay but you have to talk
but you have to tell the story the only
story I'll ask you to tell and then
we'll move on so because I can tell
you're embarrassed is you have to tell
the story of what happened while we were
sitting there and you kept getting up in
the middle of our for the first time
that we ever met and as it people know I
am incredibly facetious I like to joke
around if anything obnoxious or
embarrassing happens around me I let
people know and just keep that in mind
as you hear this story and how kind of a
person I am so let me set the scene
first of all it is a cold December day
walking in a blizzard I literally had to
stop at a CVS because I was crying from
the like wind you're gonna fix her
makeup because she was coming to meet me
okay so I get to the coffee shop I meet
him and he's wearing a hat you had on a
hoodie and you had on jeans that were
like way too big for you remember
because you were really skinny well it's
really skinny I was skinny at the time
but they were normal fitting jeans I
just lost a lot of weight oh yeah and
and then we got coffee and I got a
cappuccino and I sat down in the super
crowded coffee shop so they were like
people walking in and out I was like
right in there and it was so cold that I
had this massive heavy coat with me and
the stupid little chairs were like way
too small and flimsy so when you put
your coat on if you're not sitting on
the chair but you get up your chair
falls
so I heard them say like cappuccino and
I was like oh is that mine so would get
up and my chair would fall and like oh
okay that's what happened one time
and her cappuccino was not there so she
came back sat down oh my god I came with
my chair fell over that was embarrassing
okay I did not say a word if it didn't
say a word
kept talking she thought that she heard
a second time them call so she stood up
chair fell over a second time she
realized that's not my cappuccino and my
chair fell over sets it back up sits
back down I do not say a word and
finally a third time they actually call
her name as if the first two times
weren't a good lesson she stands up and
the chair falls over a third time and
she goes and she gets the cappuccino and
comes back and it took every ounce of
self-discipline I have to not say a
single word and she picked up or I think
I actually picked up the chair you sat
back down and we continue the
conversation as if the chair didn't fall
over three times okay so that happened
all right can you also tell the one
story remember when I asked you if you
were athletic back in high school I just
want you to tell the story of the time
that you pulled your muscle in the New
York Public Library okay this is only
this is the last embarrassing story I
asked you to tell and then we'll move on
to important things so we were walking
around and I don't know why he loves
this story so much but we're walking and
walking up the stairs and suddenly I
pulled a muscle I don't know I have no
idea what happened the bitch's bike went
down oh I'm literally dying like the
most nerd thing of all time literally
walking through the library she pulled a
muscle in her hamstring and like not in
like a fashion of like oh that kind of
hurt my grab your leg like as in though
like oh I just got shot but she grabbed
her leg and literally like threw her
purse at me and like hobbled for a
second and I had to look around and I
was like well did somebody stab you what
happened I did nice guy
very nice guy actually carried your
purse did not look like a man purse
actually looked like I was carrying a
female's first throughout the near
public library all right
so let's go back to actual real stories
now that I've been embarrassing you
you're at fortune you're doing term
sheet and three years ago you start the
profile yeah all right tell us about the
profile so three years ago I was like I
want to do something creative for myself
that involved really like good long form
journalism because at the time a lot of
media organizations were kind of
aggregating a lot of stories it was it
was a lot to read a lot of crap get
through before you could get through
like the media stories so I was like oh
great this email and I'll compile some
of the best profiles because I really
love profiles on people and companies
that I find across the web whether
that's fortune Forbes GQ ESPN Sports
Illustrated all sorts of publications
and put them together in one email and
actually I'm a very indecisive person so
I kept going back and forth should I do
it should I don't should I not and you
were like just do it like what's like
what's the big deal I think I think
that's the best thing about you is like
you always minimize really serious
situations for me and like if are they
serious it's not like you're gonna die
it's like like pretty much my life is
evaluated on am I gonna die or is there
zero chance of dying and doing this 90
well for me by 85% of the things here
and that you're not gonna die
a category so pay for them yet once you
get into that you're not gonna die
category it's like what's the risk
reward and 95% of those things are like
super high reward compared to the risk
so like why not do it did that did you
did that mentality come from after you
went to war I so like it would be safe
answer to say yes but like no that's
probably why I ended up in the middle of
Iraq at one point was because my entire
life I grew up with four brothers and we
were just like I think subconsciously we
just would say things like we're not
gonna die so we would go do crazy [ __ ]
like one day I'll bring my brothers on
here and we'll do will tell the stories
of when we were kids and like the things
that we did looking back I have no clue
how all five of us are still alive and
all five of us still have every arm and
leg no clue but that's basically taking
that evaluation of decisions as a child
to like now it's like okay you want to
start this thing like go do it yeah stop
talking about it so yes I was talking
about it for a long time and then
finally he was like why don't you just
do it and I did it and I loved it all
right so you started three years ago and
you just quit fortune left
what quit sounds bad but you left to go
do this full-time
why did you leave like there's a
receptacle a devil's advocate there's a
recession that's occurring you had a
great job
lots of people thought it was an
important job you got to talk to cool
people all the time and then you're like
leaving for this thing that nobody knows
ya know in you know this like I love
CeCe I get to say stuff and when we're
interviewing that she'd get mad at me
for otherwise alright go ahead and now I
have to think about what you said for
something to get mad at you about leader
but ya know I loved fortune and the best
part of it was term-sheet and talking to
the community of people and getting to
interview so many I mean I took to it
like moment the gates like when do you
ever get to interview Melinda Gates so
she's a gangster she is
um but I started I think it was back in
January I kind of started thinking about
like I had a lot going on at work at
fortune and I wasn't really dedicating
that much time to the profile not as
much as I would have loved to and I was
like what would what would it look like
if I just did this full-time 100% and
gave it all my attention and I started
thinking about ideas and like this and
that and whatever and I just could not
decide like I kept it was kind of
miserable cuz like I would wake up and
be like oh my god I want to do this and
I go to bed no no no no I can't I can't
I can't and I kept going back and forth
and just like mentally that's really
disruptive so he made me write down like
a list of reasons to leave reasons not
to and yeah can we talk about this can
we talk about this list so finally for
everyone that's out there if you have a
significant other if you have a good
friend if you have anyone who's going
through one of these times where they
don't know what to do it's usually
pretty obvious to the other people in
their life like it was obvious for a
while that you should go do this because
you really enjoyed doing it
you just were being a scaredy-cat that's
basically what it was you were
overwhelmed by the illusion of risk not
by the actual risk you thought of more
risky than it was and so I basically
made you make the list so that you would
stop asking me every five seconds what I
thought and I said make the list and
then we'll talk about it yeah into your
credit you never have said do this or do
that or whatever even though like in
those times I think if you're a person
like me you like kind of crave knock
validation yeah kind of validation and
like somebody telling me like yes this
is the right decision but like you never
said yes this is absolutely the right
decision or that is the right decision
sighs I didn't want to be blamed if you
did something and it didn't work like
it's not it's not my choice it's your
choice yeah all right so you make this
list and ladies and gentlemen let me
tell you this list was pathetic and
pathetic in the sense of the list of why
to do it was super long the list of why
not to do it was complete
and utter nonsense it was like people
might not like it if I do this what else
I get in my own way it was like it was
like legitimate things that are like not
trivial concerns but when you compared
them risk to reward the risk was
pathetically less than the reward right
but you also have to understand like
this is a place where I spent five years
and I think a lot of my identity was
tied up into it and to suddenly say no
no I'm gonna do this thing that nobody
knows at all and it doesn't even like
not even like a real organization that's
backed by any sort of credibility except
myself
you're really counting on people
trusting you to do to make it good hey
here's a free knowledge bomb for you
guys you'd never be happier or freer
than when your identity is tied to your
name right just be you yeah but so then
so then okay so I make this decision and
finally I'm like I'm gonna do this
full-time I'm gonna go for it and a few
days later a corona virus hits and I'm
like oh my god there's gonna be a
recession there's a virus what the virus
was spreading in honestly it was in a
weird way if there was so much
uncertainty that I think my brain just
kind of like freaked out and calm down
because on it nobody knows what's gonna
happen there's so much uncertainty that
you can't even plan so so I started it
at a time where a lot of uncertainty but
at the same time I think a lot of people
want to read good high-quality content
and they have time for it so in a weird
twisted way I'm hoping that that's one
positive thing that came from this all
right and so what has been the response
from people when you've told them that
you are gonna go do this full-time
because this was one of the biggest
things I think we disagreed on that I
told you was true and you didn't believe
me but I think now you agree
overwhelmingly positive people are
really nice like they are really really
kind humans but what did I tell when I
saw
told you if you go to do this people
will help you
what was my logic for it and do you
agree with it now I think your logic was
if you put something into the world
people will want to support you and help
you build it because you know that's how
people are yeah can you tell if you tell
people your goals they're more likely to
want to help you be successful than they
are to judge you for that being your
goal right I didn't know that I thought
people would be judgmental and the
questions I thought I was gonna get is
why on earth would you ever leave a safe
secure job to do something so crazy
you're more likely to get questions like
why on earth you hanging out with that
guy than you are all right so how's the
profile going so far it's going great in
the last I'm doing it for a week and a
half and not week and a half I've
literally interviewed seven small
business owners to ask them about how
the coronavirus shutdown is affecting
their business I today I published a Q&A
with a photographer who went viral
during the quarantine for asking a girl
out by sending her drone with his phone
number on it but he's also he does a lot
of portrait photography so we talked
about that and then I'm also planning
some virtual events for next week
and so I'm staying busy alright so the
first day was last Monday working at the
profile and for somebody who is in and
constantly talking to founders and
investing and having built companies
before excetera I think one of the
things that you forget is the excitement
and enthusiasm of starting a company and
especially the first time on day one etc
and polina's says to me last Monday she
goes today's my first day at the profile
I hope my colleagues like and it just
cracked me up because it was such a like
pure view and
- like the enthusiasm of starting
something are you still excited I'm so
excited I love it why I just ha there's
something about like doing something for
other people that gives you joy um I
genuinely like I'm excited to send them
the newsletter and I'm like oh my god
they're gonna learn something today cuz
I learned something you know what I mean
yeah so I still love it alright and so
you've got tens of thousands of people
on the free list you've got I don't
think I'm allowed to say how many paying
but a good amount I'm pretty impressed
actually I thought that she was gonna do
well but she's doing much better than I
it's not mansplaining naira it's it's a
thing where whenever you see somebody
start something just in your head you're
like here would be like a conservative
outcome really a good outcome here would
be a great outcome and the great outcome
at this point like you've surpassed that
already so it's like I couldn't have
even imagined you doing this well so as
a compliment not mansplaining I would
actually know what what is man's point I
think you just I feel like that's a
woman's planning but okay and then
you're also doing the dossiers yeah
explain that and so for the paying tier
I've added a new section called the
profile dossier where we go I do a deep
dive on a prominent individual every
Wednesday in the way I kind of structure
it is I don't think of the person first
I think about an idea that I want to
learn about so last week it was
uncertainty and I was like the world is
so uncertain right now I want to know
how people navigate chaos and how they
have confidence and making decisions and
times of chaos so I was like who's the
best person that would embody that so I
immediately thought of Annie Duke who's
a professional poker player and she
talks a lot about decision-making when
you actually don't have an idea of what
the future holds so coming from that I
did an information binge on her and
compiled the best ideas from her
interviews podcast
TEDTalks everything she's done into one
dossier so I'm biased obviously go sign
up to the profile read the profile calm
and you get what it when people sign up
if they're on the free list they get
every Sunday a whole list of
recommendation
in all honesty of long form written
profiles right and things like everyone
from Kanye West to gates to must whoever
that you finally isn't it and then if
you're a paying member what do I get you
get you get that email you also get two
sections of recommendations of audio and
video so that those include podcast
speeches interviews TED talks and
documentaries and then you also get the
profile dossier and you also are added
to a telegram group of other profile
readers where we talk about all sorts of
stuff and debate all sorts of ideas and
it's my favorite place on the internet
and then in the future I'll also have
member only events as well got it okay
how much does it cost it costs $10 a
month or $50 a year it's a great
investment yeah why wouldn't be what is
by to no-brainer
okay all right moving on so I'm just
saying we're gonna take we took a bunch
of questions from the audience some of
them are hilarious so we're gonna get to
that in a second but I want to ask you
about two things one is what's gonna
happen in media and then second she
doesn't even know I'm gonna ask her
about this we just watched Tiger King
we're definitely gonna talk about it
alright so what's the state of media
today and where do you think this is
going yeah so I think you and I talk
about this a lot but like the idea that
you build an audience and that audience
is absolutely key to the link products
or building new things in the future but
what I think
my opinion is that people subscribes to
people subscribe to people not large
faceless organizations so that means
that's why if you notice newsletters are
having such a moment why Twitter
personalities are having such a moment
people want to know like it's just much
easier for me to build a
lationship with you as a person versus
the whole organization so in my opinion
it's like if I have a favorite profile
writer at GQ and I only go to GQ to read
her stories why on earth would I want to
subscribe to all of GQ and get all of
their stories when I could just
subscribe to her and date her directly
and know that she is making money and I
was supporting her that way I think
that's the future of media all right and
speaking of media Tiger King how was
that speaking of media well I mean he's
a entertainment legend what says they
Joe exotic right all right so Joe
exactly let's start with you what do you
think watch the whole thing
oh we've one episode left that aren't
actually part of it yeah go just go so
here's my opinion I for some reason I
did a podcast yesterday and I talked
about this is well I don't know why
because this is a hot topic I'm relevant
on cultural I know what's going on in
the world I'm just trying to you know
freshen things up so Juhu exotic I think
it's fascinating especially if you like
profiles and if you like people he is
like a case study all on it all on his
own but also the people around him like
it's amazing to me that him and Carol
are such different people Teknik Carol's
a woman that he tried to kill I don't
know stop with the spoilers so Carol and
him are very different they have
different worldviews but they're
actually the same person and actually
Carol's doing it even better than he is
she's killing it on social media but I
think that basically they are running
Colts masquerading as big cat
sanctuaries or zoos do we think that she
killed her husband um I mean we don't
have all the facts but like they
presented it pretty strongly like it
seems like this guy disappeared and
there's some foul play
I don't know you don't know I don't know
look I don't know for sure but that was
kind of sketchy I mean yeah would your
big would you cry if I disappear
I cry over anything all right that's it
yes that's it yes all right let's let's
get to some of the questions from the
audience
long story short on the tiger gig is
absolutely must watch TV I mean just
incredible entertainment all right
here's the questions what's the first
one of them best in worst moments of the
quarantine life with your fiance this
comes from Charlie Bleeker
yeah like Bleecker Street all right
that's the name of a street right yeah
all right Bleecker Street in New York
City
yeah of court lame you know you've gotta
get some pizza had Domino's last night
don't judge all right best and worst
moments of Quarantine life with your
fiance you go first best best yeah um
it's kind of fun to like annoy you all
the time not as fun as when he annoys me
wait can I say the worst though yeah
okay so the other day I'm in bed I am
asleep
it is 7:00 in the morning and suddenly
I'm like woken up by him jump like
literally jumping like a rocket out of
bed can't say who it is running out we
won guess it is running out on speak on
speakerphone talking about like
coronavirus theories in so here's the
short story is I have this problem where
I'm so used to always talking on
speakerphone or with ear pods in like I
forget that the phone works if you put
it to your ear which sounds ridiculous
but just whatever and so I got woken up
by somebody calling me and I jumped up
out of bed and ran in the other room and
was talking to this person but I had it
on speakerphone and there was a text
message that was sent to me but because
I was on speakerphone and I was talk ID
I didn't notice and the text message was
fairly aggressive so yes the whole
communication out loud I've learned that
the headphone situation I actually even
have headphones here with cords so that
when the air pods die I'm ready to go
that's yeah not it's fine
best and worst
moments of quarantine life with my
fiance well so the best is I say
all-time Linda is absolutely my best
friend we have a blast together she did
not pay me to say that either she didn't
have enough money to pay me 8:00 to say
that because I don't have enough money
to pay her to say that about me either
because we actually love each other but
see he says you guys see how I'm getting
points right now the worst moment was
not to do with her but we had to
reschedule our wedding so we were gonna
get married in the middle of April we
had to push it out a couple of months to
it to another date and it was the worst
because you have to coordinate with all
of these vendors all these people and
we're having a very small wedding
with basically just our families and so
not like a lot of logistical problems
but you really get to tell somebody's
who they really are when they're faced
with these times of turmoil and what is
very calm cool collected etc very kind
to people pretty much the opposite of
meet a lot of times but there was one
person an airline United who would not
give us a refund for flights for people
from outside of the country coming here
even though that country has a ban on
travel so literally is against the
government's law to have those people
travel to the United States and United
would not give us a refund and so
pl'anna in a very unexpected yet still
polite but very unexpected way explain
to them that they were going to give us
a refund and so I think seeing you upset
was a bad part of this because then when
you're upset you know everybody knows
you know happy wife happy life unhappy
we gotta you know just be on pins and
needles walk on some glass a little
interview is that I feel like I don't
think you've ever gotten mad at me for
something I'm chill am I not sure do you
think that's because I'm just an angel
and I do
that's so far from what the reason why
is not even close but I don't get mad at
you because again going back to the
framework of evaluation am I going to
die the equivalent in a relationship is
is this a reason for her to leave or me
to leave no I'm childen whatever knock
yourself out
but if it ever was something like that
and I probably would be so chill except
I will say I have witnessed him I've
never played I don't think I've ever
played like a game with you one-on-one
so it's like chess and you're terrible
like you get mad you get upset cuz I'm
competitive and I was smoking here
listen to this nonsense I was up five
nothing I won five games in a row five
like when I was a kid if you beat
somebody badly enough at a game they
have to go home like this they're done
like playing Madden you're up 21 they
got to go home Oh
but when yeah but so I was up five other
than like if you lose five games of
chess in a row you should be banned
retired forever from chess and then all
of a sudden she started cheating like
she would do things like oh the dominoes
is here go get the dominoes and so I
have to go get the dominoes and then
when I would come back she was like
analyzing the board for like 25 minutes
and I'm like of course you are better
prepared to play this game than me no
okay so the second question here comes
from Stephan Stephan Stephan Olman on
Twitter and he says how do you approach
conversations when you disagree about
something in both feel you have
supporting data / information go ahead
ah well it's really hard to like argue
assume very like convincing in a way
that's like you're annoying I'm a great
debater and I'm also chill which is a
deadly combination you debate and you
don't get heated when I debate I lose my
[ __ ] so who looks like the angel now on
this relationship No
I feel that way so anyway so when I feel
strongly about something pray for me
pray for me guys I I think and I think
most of our arguments have been overly
stupid things where you won't agree with
me yeah
like I I like I cannot exist in a world
where we can have different opinions and
you will see my side or like you won't
know what frustrates polina is i'm
actually i believe right i think i'm
self-aware enough this i'm actually very
good at saying i see your side but i
disagree and printed that like doesn't
comprehend it or anything like there's
no computation that ends in that result
it's either if you see my side than you
agree with me or you don't see my side
the the mixture of those two things are
very hard for her to comprehend and so
you know me being a kind person i just
allow it to go and that keep going so
let's move on to the third question
comes from kevin kelly from delphi
digital great great guys over there and
he says in all honesty reaching down
into your core do you think he always
talked about me do you think me do you
think he'd rather give up McDonald's or
Bitcoin Jesus Christ all right what do
you think definitely you would
definitely give up
Bitcoin before you gave up McDonald's
for life is the boldest claim I've ever
heard I mean not a french fry ever again
like watching me eat them
the fries are pretty good but I you know
what I like better at McDonald's in the
fries people are gonna get real mad
about this that make flurries like that
they're amazing like if they sold if
they sold frozen make flurries at like
the gas stations and the Duane Reade's
and CBS's and grocery stores etc I would
get one every day so what's the verdict
I'd give up McDonald's for sure did you
give up McDonald's yeah from Bitcoin
yeah oh it's cuz like ones fleeting the
others gonna be here forever
just sayin it's not an ad it's just the
truth
good master BTC LTC by the way we love
the the Twitter avatars the gifts and
and the usernames that people wrote in
go ahead do you actually understand
Bitcoin how annoyed do you get with pomp
being on Twitter and do you and pump
send each other means when you wanted to
do something I so I understand the
premise of Bitcoin and I know a little
just from like hearing you talk about it
non-stop but I can't say that I could
have like a legitimate like long
conversation okay so let's test your
knowledge okay how many Bitcoin are
there right now or ever ever 20 million
wrong
oh you're close to 21 21 million 21
million basically got it right and then
if you had to describe Bitcoin in one
sentence what would that one sentence be
it is an asymmetric your alleged an
asymmetric non-correlated acid that's a
fact okay what's next
how annoyed do you get with pop being on
Twitter I think that's the biggest yeah
probably like so like today I walked out
I thought he was looking out the window
like enjoying the life like looking out
and I just feel like he's like on
Twitter scrolling I was answering I was
answering something I don't know it's
just a lot polina you thinks have any
tips on like mmm work-life balance with
somebody who does their business on
Twitter let me know polina has convinced
me to put my phone down more than I
previously did yeah like we take walks
and you don't it's true cuz I got a
Apple watch though in case anything
happens
all right go ahead wasn't that uh do we
send memes to each other um listen I'm
gonna meme God when it comes to sin and
memes but i lately what is it a mean
yeah on Instagram
yeah the meme accounts i ID I use the DM
thing where you taking you DM it and I
just send it to her with no context and
then showed respect why the [ __ ] did you
just send me these guys sitting in a
living room on the couch watching
guerrillas fight on YouTube I'm like
that's what they're betting on now that
sports are over there's stuff like that
and sometimes the camera zone he'll send
me something on he'll damn me something
on Twitter and it's like 17 charts with
like 18 lines don't like what is this
and he's like oh sorry I just I just
send it to you so I could like use it as
a bookmarking tool for myself yeah I
saved it for myself so like what else
understand what he wants to say and then
I just send it to you so that I could go
back later and get it I'd love to hear
in summary of common themes you've
noticed when researching successful
individuals and companies bonus what's
one useful thing you've won from each
other alright what's the summary of
common themes you've noticed when
researching successful individuals and
companies so the one thing I've learned
is that there's this there was this
really great profile run on a guy who is
works as a in a bodega and he makes
sandwiches and he's from Egypt so a job
stand up good that's felt like we're in
a music video so but he's actually he's
really really he has like a studio that
he's made in the bathroom of the bodega
and he's actually like a political
pundit in Egypt talk about America and
like you know different political things
going on here and how it affects Egypt
so every day at like a certain time
he'll go into the bathroom and then you
know like you have a camera set up
there's there's a map I think behind him
and he does that he does both and my
thing is I I love that you can be more
than one thing in life like you are
never just X or just Y you can be a
political pundit and you know a bodega
owner or whatever you mean whenever you
may be doing in life but I think for me
that's really important because I tend
to find something and wrap my entire
identity around it and I think that
thinking in that way it's really helpful
what's what's one useful thing you've
learned for me and then out people with
I learned from you um so I'm not pretty
like a moody person so like it takes
like one thing to ruin my mood and I'm
like ah like the entire day is ruined
and I think what I've learned from you
is that like you know you're always just
like having fun and not you you don't
let the little small minutia ruin your
whole day
yeah people can't shake me it's fine
the one thing I've learned from polina
is to sleep before I met her ah Savage I
would I'd literally sleep like four
hours a day I was just you ever heard
the saying anything worth doing in life
is worth overdoing
that's basically was my motto in life
and then I met plain and she was like
let me teach you about drinking more
water let me drink teach you about
sleeping a little bit etc and at first I
resisted amazing everyone should sleep
eight hours sleep nine if you can it's
amazing drink water a lot of water is
good for you I didn't know that I just
think it was soft to drink water but yes
I learned that drink water and go to
sleep
yeah all right master Higgins last one
this is last one yeah all right between
the two of you who owns more crypto at
the moment Jesus Christ guide Telmar
rule okay so I don't own any one time we
tried it but like it didn't let me
because I don't think that was in the
right State good yeah
not mental state like actual state of
America yeah so so yeah so no I do not
own any crypto he says that you take all
the risk and
I basically plan has got to make sure
that if I ever blow myself up that I
don't blow both of us up at the same
time so our rule is that I'm exotic joe
yeah joe exotic we don't need we don't
need a joe exotic pulling in wasn't the
guy Jeff low Jeff low scooting in with a
but by the way if we don't get haircuts
if like America can't get haircuts I
want to know are we going bandanas
mullets or both you were doing just so
you guys know if I'm not out of here by
the end of April I will have a mullet
that's all I'm saying
by the end of April by the end of April
if we are not out of quarantine I'm
gonna get Polina to look at YouTube to
look it where they call them tutorials
tutorials on YouTube and she's gonna cut
my hair into a mullet no fact watch so
alright any of the parting words oh wait
I have questions for you what's your
favorite book my favorite yeah your
favorite book
I don't read well can I say one that I
really liked yeah you say whatever you
want that's basically you're showing
this so I really so I really liked a
house in the sky it's about this it's a
true story it's a memoir it's about a
Canadian journalist who went to Somalia
and got kidnapped and held hostage for
about a year
it's pretty intense but I mean it's the
most amazing thing I've ever read it's
really well-written
she's a really great storyteller and the
things that happened in her life like
really put everything into perspective
can I ask a question because I'm
genuinely curious what is the
fascination that millennial girls have
with murder mystery so I'm not saying
you are but like it just reminded like
that's not a look that most people would
recommend but at the same time like I
wouldn't think that people would listen
to like podcasts going over like murders
but they're incredibly popular and then
there's like cereal he's like crime
drama like stuff I think what see what
is that fascination
like I think it's like the mystery and
kind of like thrill of a you know you're
on the subway you're listening to it did
they catch him to be not it's like I
don't know that's like it's like an
adrenaline thing like why do you do the
crazy stuff you do well I don't do
anything crazy just it's just crazy to
other people this because they're dumb
alright last question and then you get
ask me one question the people want to
know do you believe in aliens oh I I do
why why don't we never actually have
talked about yeah so I definitely think
like heroes are so ridiculously selfish
and argue goes are so big that to
concede that there's like even the
smallest possibility that there are
aliens out there like other forms of
intelligence wait do you remember the
other day when I asked you when I asked
you if you thought that like coronavirus
could actually be like an alien species
remember well I don't think it's a
species yeah I couldn't think an alien
yeah infiltrator yeah I don't think it's
an alien but okay it could have come
from somewhere else sure but anyway yes
I definitely think that there's other
would you go to space uh no why I like
earth what if I went would you come with
me no so so when we go on when we go on
vacation or like plana knows that me and
her are gonna be around my brother's
Polina will usually say to me before we
go you're not gonna make me do anything
crazy with you guys right I know but
like going to space is it like ice it is
kind of crazy but maybe not it depends
on how safe it is all right well one
question do you have for me to do this
recording by the way has been in the
making for a very long time Polina
has been offended that we haven't
recorded this sooner well no I was just
waiting for the right time and so guess
when we're gonna release it on April
Fool's Day
okay ask me your question let's go I got
things to do today I wasn't gonna ask
what question what is okay what is the
biggest like specific thing that you
learned being in Iraq that you brought
back with you to the US everyone's gonna
die really yeah like what you know like
one of the biggest takeaways I had from
war is the idea of like humanizing death
in some weird way and maybe that's not
the right way to describe it but what I
mean by humanizing death is the concept
of death is not something that people
experience on a very frequent basis and
so when they experience it especially
when it is with somebody that they know
or in a situation that they can relate
to etc I think that there's a big impact
like here's a here's a very watered-down
example put it example when Kobe Bryant
died the collective experience that
everyone had of like I've watched this
guy felt like I saw him grow up I
watched him play basketball like I know
everything about his life he's my age
right like all of these things like oh
he had a family like I bit like whatever
he crashed and like it was all taken
away from unexpectedly like that could
be me yeah all of a sudden I think
people are like whoa
and they reassessed certain parts of
their life and kind of how they focus on
things whatever that is a very extended
version of that experience the closer it
is to you I think that you see people
just like it sticks with them for longer
right and so I remember coming back and
like it wasn't so much that I was like
different in the way that I looked at
life as much as it was I just knew going
back to the whole like are you gonna die
or not oh you're not gonna die like
there's basically no risk then right
because you changed the way that you
think about risk when you realize you
can always reinvent yourself you can
always try something fail and like and
you know survive you
can always take a lot of risk and be
fine whether it goes well or not like
all of a sudden you start to change the
way you look at risk reward frameworks
and so I would say easily like that was
the one thing where you just like oh
[ __ ] like yeah like if this is a video
game we all die right like there's no
escaping alive and so if that's the case
then like you don't know when that's
gonna happen so like just go live your
[ __ ] life like have a blast right and
so like that's why I'm probably so like
carefree and have so much fun it's like
I have more fun than anybody in the
world hands down like I promise you
literally there's times where people I
know will be like she'll walk into the
living room should be like what are you
doing and I'll just be like having a
blast by myself she's just like you're
[ __ ] weird but like I'm happy that
you're happy and it's just like I
literally could be by myself I could be
with a bunch of friends I'd be with
complete strangers I could be with you I
could be with a dog like whatever I'm
gonna have a blast
is that fair all right
go subscribe read the profile support
Polina
please don't tweet anything bad that I
said at me she is very lovely oh yeah or
not alright so the last thing I'll leave
you guys with is anyone who's listening
to this probably is has a similar
Twitter experience to me in that yeah
there's a lot of trolls and kind of
combativeness whether it's in technology
finance crypto business whatever there's
just kind of a lot of I was taught I
can't say that word the the D word
measurement like everyone's you know
dick measuring whatever is fine but she
doesn't like when I say that but like
that a lot of that stuff goes on and
people are always like trying to one-up
each other and be combative and one day
Polina handed me her phone on Twitter
and I was like this is the nicest place
in the world these people are so kind to
each other like what where what Twitter
are you on because I think I got the
other version yeah he was driving and I
was like I don't know hoping you tweet
or something and I kept refreshing the
feed and it was like I mean there were a
lot of notification
like 90% of them were like you know hope
you have an awful day or something like
meaner than that that would be that
would be a nice comment my favorite is I
have a group chat with with my brothers
and I got a couple of friends and
there's times where I've literally like
woken up see him notification I'll
screenshot it and I'll send it to them
and a big a random Tuesday and somebody
that we'd be like [ __ ] you pop like have
a great day guys
meanwhile in my Twitter it's like how
can we best support each other all right
guys this is a blast maybe we'll do this
a little bit more often go subscribe
read the profile calm go follow Polina
on Twitter hopefully she'll become as
addicted as I will she'll leave me alone
a little bit more let me have some fun
and we will talk to you guys soon